[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avez-vous déjà rêvé d'avoir entre les
mains une baguette magique une baguette
magique capable de tout changer de
changer les vieilles maisons en belles
maisons des ordures en fruits et légumes
des terrains abandonnés en jardins
fleuris et même la violence et
l'indifférence en convivialité une
baguette magique quoi classique donc
avec les pouvoirs d'une baguette magique
classique
un matin j'ai emmené ma fille à l'école
nous traversions comme à notre habitude
notre quartier du centre ancien de
pointe à pitre et l'ami minimiser ma
fille vous l'aurez compris me dit maman
ces maisons sont vraiment très très
moche et si tous les enfants prenaient
un pinceau et rob beignets ces maisons
on aurait de belles maisons donc un beau
quartier est une belle ville donc nous
serions heureux de vivre dans cette
belle ville en bonne maman ou ne voulant
pas froisser sa progéniture
je lui réponds mimi ton idée est
formidable mais tu sais c'est pas trop
possible
ce à quoi eric hors cac à bon c'est pas
possible mais pourquoi c'est pas
possible
à bonnes questions quelques temps après
me voilà en réunion de quartier avec
quelques voisins
quelques membres de notre association
l'objectif de la réunion trouvé le moyen
de mettre en place des actions pour
réagir un environnement qui ne nous
convient plus en effet le quartier de
notre enfance ou du faisait si bon vivre
a été envahie depuis ces dernières
années par la drogue la prostitution la
délinquance l'insalubrité
et nous habitants du quartier avions
bien l'intention de réagir
nous étions très motivés prêts à agir
agir oui mais comment et c'est alors que
l'idée de ma fille est apparu comme une
évidence
et si on commençait par repeindre nos
maisons comme dit comme fait nous nous
sommes organisés
nous avons commencé par apprendre les
bons gestes
nous avons commencé à apprendre comment
préparer des supports boucher les trous
pont s'est posée la couche d'apprêt
poser les couleurs et un peintre
professionnel qui nous a accompagnés
ensuite on s'est mis à la quête de
peinture donc on a été voir des
entreprises
au début on a trouvé des pots de
peinture on nous donnait que du bleu
vous imaginez on aurait eu un quartier
tout en bleu en fin de compte on a eu la
chance de trouver un fournisseur qui
nous a donné toutes les couleurs dont on
avait besoin est une entreprise qui nous
a fourni en matériel c'est comme ça que
l' aventure a commencé l'aventuré plus
belles larry la plus belle roche
le premier chantier a démarré en avril
2014 de cinq maisons
nous sommes passés à 12 puis à 20 puis à
50 le groupe d'une douzaine de bénévoles
s'est agrandie avec des personnes qui
venaient de partout de la guadeloupe
mais chose étonnante de métropole de
belgique du canada du portugal et même
des états unis
au fur et à mesure l'opération s'est
organisée autour de trois volets
premièrement l'embellissement des
maisons avec donc la rénovation des
façades et la mise en couleur ensuite
l'occupation des dents creuses qu'on
appelle les terrains db c'est ce qu'on
appelle dent creuse avec l'installation
de jardins partagés les installations
artistiques et le troisième volet c'est
le volet de l'animation très important
c'est le volet qui crée l
lien entre les personnes avec des bas de
quartier des gratte y feria des
projections de films en plein air et
plein d'autres événements les effets
depuis bel harry n'ont pas tardé à se
faire remarquer d'abord quand nous on
peignait une maison le propriétaire à
l'intérieur où l'occupant retaper sa
maison ensuite les voisins retaper
également leur maison donc on a eu
vraiment un effet boule de neige
ensuite les portes se sont ouvertes les
gens ont commencé à se parler
le lien humain c'est recréer l'esprit de
bon voisinage est revenu et puis l'image
du quartier a changé
donc on a eu beaucoup de reportages d'un
peu partout on a eu par exemple aussi
des artistes qui sont venus filmer leur
clip vidéo dans nos rues ou des
stylistes qui se servaient des façades
comme fonds pour leur soutien et on a
même vu des université de floride qui
sont venus nous interviewer sur notre
façon de d'appréhender la citoyenneté
mais le plus important
nous habitants du quartier nous étions
heureux d'être considéré différemment
nous n'étions plus les habitants des
quartiers mal famés de pointe à pitre
nous étions les habitants du quartier de
plus belle la vie
dans le passé j'ai travaillé de longues
années sur des grands projets
d'aménagement autant qu architecte
urbaniste des grands projets de
rénovation urbaine des opérations de
résorption de l'habitat insalubre des
schémas de cohérence territoriale et je
me suis rapidement rendu compte du
décalage qui avait entre c'est tous ces
documents prospectifs et la réalité du
terrain
l'objectif annoncé de tous ces documents
étaient toujours très ambitieux
améliorer le cadre de vie des citoyens
mais savait-on comment vraiment s'y
prendre et si à la place des grosses
opérations de démolition reconstruction
on envisageait des solutions moins
catégorique
plus subtil plus à l'écouté des usagers
plus respectueuse du lien humain et si à
la place de ces opérations on
envisageait d'autres procédés les mots
clés de ces procédés projet participatif
intelligence collective complémentarité
humanité solidarité des opérations ou
les prescripteurs serait aussi les
utilisateurs un peu comme dans plus
belle la rive des opérations qu'on
pourrait qualifier de relooking urbain
où on s'occuperait aussi bien de la
forme que du fond qui permettrait à des
quartiers de revivre de garder leur âme
et de s'appuyer sur l'implication des
habitants et des citoyens quel que soit
le nom qu'on peut donner à ces
opérations quelle que soit la chose que
on ait envie de changer il ya toujours
moyen de provoquer le changement
et vous y at il quelque chose que vous
auriez aimé changer autour de vous
forcément il y aura il ya quelque chose
que vous auriez aimé changer
on a tous des talents
des caractères particuliers demandez
vous comment vous pouvez mettre ses
atouts au service du changement et
maintenant est-ce qu'on peut changer la
couleur d'une maison avec un pinceau
peut-on changer l'ambiance d'un quartier
avec un pinceau peut tout changer une
ville avec un pinceau moi je dis oui
bien sûr plus bel harry en a fait la
démonstration et ont fait la
démonstration tous les jours mais
gardons à l'esprit que ce qui donne le
pouvoir à notre baguette magique
c'est notre conviction accompagné de
notre motivation ou le contraire notre
motivation accompagnée de nos
convictions
ça peut marcher dans les deux sens en
fait et maintenant que je vous ai livré
tous les secrets de ma baguette magique
vous n'avez plus qu'à répondre à une
seule question et vous quel est ou quel
sera votre baguette magique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]